let's start off by defining a new
function f and it's the natural log of X
everything that we're interested in is
the natural logs or natural
Exponential's and so on okay
now by definition you might remember and
it's actually going to be very useful
for us in this that Ln X is just an
abbreviation for log with what base e
very good so I'm gonna pop that in the
reason why I'm doing that is because it
helps me do the next step which is to
take this log equation and rewrite
everything you see there but as an
exponential equation I'm gonna do that
because I know how to handle
Exponential's we've said this before
I'll say it again a lot of mathematics
is devoted to taking problems that you
don't know how to deal with and rephrase
them or reframe them so they look like
problems you do know how to deal with
and then you deal with them okay so help
me remember and I'll give you a quick
example just to just to get their out if
I said log base 2 of 32 I asked you to
evaluate it without your calculator it
would tell you 5 that's a log equation
can you help me rewrite and the numbers
hopefully are easy enough that you could
even guess can you help me rewrite this
log equation as an exponential equation
I'll give you a clue start with the base
- yep the base say is the base to the
power of 5 gives you 32 ok fantastic so
this is what we're going to do but on
this line okay so we started with the
base here which was 2 what's the base in
this equation it's 8 so I'm gonna write
I write it over here e that's gonna be
my base what's my power f of X this guy
over here becomes the power f of X and
then what do I have left there's only
one thing it's just the X it's just the
X ok so what I've done is I've rewritten
this log equation as an exponential and
I'm really good at dealing with
Exponential's so good then I'm gonna
take this line left hand side right hand
side and I'm going to differentiate both
sides let me send it again here's an
equation you can do the same thing the
same operation to both sides and
everything is fine right you could
multiply both sides by 2 you could add 1
to both sides I'm going to
for rent she ate both sides like so okay
is that alright this just means
differentiate whatever you can see there
okay I will start on the right hand side
for this even though that's a bit
backwards but I'm just doing it cuz it's
easy the dream either there just X what
is that it's just it's just one right in
fact you could write it as DX on DX
which is one so I've got one on the
right hand side on the left hand side
this is not as easy but you can still do
it
I need the chain rule on this okay can
someone help me how do I deal with this
using the chain rule we did a whole
bunch but over there what are we gonna
do chain rule right it requires looking
at the inside function and then the
outside function here is the inside
function what's the derivative of the
inside function it's just F dash X like
I don't know what f of X is so I'm just
gonna write its derivative is f dash
there's the inside derivative
what's the outside derivative yeah it's
just like it's e to the power of a thing
e to the power of thing differentiates
into the same thing so I'm gonna write
the same thing a different this is the
inside derivative this is the outside
derivative okay all right now I'm almost
there I'm very very close okay what I'm
really after is is this guy do you see
that like this is the part I want F dash
because I want to differentiate this guy
yeah so I want to get that by itself I'm
gonna change the subject so it's just
this so what should I do to both sides
of this equation
yeah yeah this thing here is like the
thing in the way right so I'm gonna just
divide both sides by that okay which
gives me F dash X on the Left what does
give me on the right 1 over 1 over this
is that okay is that right
wait a second wait a second I divided
both sides by this yeah look closely
this eat a pair of effects that I just
divided by look up a few lines I can
write that in a much simpler way can't I
have a look right here there it is
e to the power FX it's just X like by
definition you help me write this
equation right
so therefore F dash X what's it equal to
it's 1 over X which is what we sort of
guessed that before when we looked at
the picture but just looking at a
picture like our eyes famously
unreliable this is watertight calculus
okay we had to use a log laws we had to
use chain rule stuff that we've looked
at this year but what I love about this
is there's no arguing with this there's
no kind of like oh maybe it's it's
clearly every single line flows on to
the next one you might not have guessed
oh how did you know to do this and then
this right you know I got taught that by
someone else and now I'm passing on the
lesson what's great about it is this
this is a proof there's logic that goes
all the way through this no guesswork no
estimation no intuition it's absolutely
true which is kind of a super power of
mathematics as a whole so just to tie
that in an ebow do you need this no but
just as a whole I think you should not
have to accept things because someone
tells you they are all of that is stuff
which we've looked at within the scope
of the course so that's why I wanted to
to hand it to you